it smells so great oh that's just a
clean person it's happening to us guys
I'm here with Megan Batu and I'm so
excited I'm excited I have been obsessed
with Megan's videos for probably the
last year and finally I haven't enticed
her over to my house to participate in a
challenge that only she and I could
really really relish in together
it's an autumn candle sniffing challenge
rolls off the tongue we have collected
an assortment of Bath and Body Works
autumn scented candles and we will be
blindfolded and smelling them and trying
to guess what the candle name is do you
feel confident in this absolutely not
yeah that's how I feel too
I just had like a moment of reflection
on what this challenge actually is and I
yeah this is gonna be bad Jack very
producer/director extraordinaire is
going to read us the names of all the
candles that have been purchased because
we don't know which ones are actually
here with us today
here's the fun thing about candle names
is they have no relevance to the smell
okay so what are the possible names they
are feel like you're pausing is it this
is like the American Idol finale and
we're gonna find out who wins all right
so we've got leaves caramel pumpkin
swirl Oh pumpkin cupcake Oh
marshmallow fireside what's up frosted
cranberry do they do that
vanilla pumpkin marshmallow next is
autumn Thanksgiving morning pumpkin
pecan waffles
that's the same one Thanksgiving morning
/ no it's not on Wallace are you joking
why would you give it to net weight no I
don't work for Bath & Body Works you
guys yeah person probably doesn't either
mahogany teak wood yeah coarse sand and
cedar wood okay okay what expert we're
gonna have to smell it out thank you we
gotta smell it out I'm so ready are you
ready I'm pumped me up okay let's do
this and then we just shout it out until
someone gets it kind of cold this pit
room okay your eyes closed right now -
yes I don't know I do this under
blindfolds I close my eyes and smell
Thanksgiving morning pecans muffled but
mahogany teak wood yes that's the only
one I could remember it smells great
then I choose a great like teak wood
yeah that's not a table where palate
cleanser so Thanksgiving morning souffle
pecan waffles oh wait
pumpkin cupcake cranberry frosting
mother oh it's - I'm gonna loop cake
matters yes this is not with leaving oh
you could relieve in like a Glade plugin
oh my god okay yeah smell Thanksgiving
morning yes but I don't remember any
other day it's saying that went over it
so you got it it smells like like a
Cinnabon
okay ready ready smell 100 different um
what's the matter
she is it pink
with it um either that sessom um the
other would one you know what yeah like
huffing this into my um my nose couldn't
be further it's and berry oh that sound
like a right answer but it can we get a
hint I was a summary I was
that's the hitch it's quite fall oh yeah
when you're blindfolded and you're just
like huffing sense into your face it is
quite an experience to to - oh my god
well this one oh oh no some mini meteor
frosted cranberry Oh pumpkin coming yeah
oh yeah you this does smell exactly like
a pumpkin okay
it really does it they literally haven't
had is really great I want to hate you
so much
yeah smell cedar plank salmon what um
with uh what um pumpkin is it anything
with a pumpkin cranberry frosting what's
the other ones what are the vanilla
sprinkles cupcake marshmallow fire oh I
don't make s'mores that just throw
marshmallows deep into the fire but
familiar smooth oh my our shits are
sweating profusely this is why I wore
this shirt in three two one
smell what this is really yes
no this is ivory spring I'll be like a
man's armpit this is a man's so if you
are concerned about college and like
what your future holds all you need to
know is take a look at what you're
looking at right now reach for the sky
yeah it's my whoo probably creepy yes I
was not chosen yet and also this is
joyful this is what the dick
oh did you it did make a Megan I do it
congratulations thank you I'm really
proud of you you guys want to see more
impressive things please go over to
Megan's channel here on YouTube because
she does a variety of wonderful very
cool entertaining things if you'd like
to hear us engage in more dumb
conversation please go listen to the
full podcast that we are about to record
on iTunes or SoundCloud not to do for
grace Helbig and Megan Mattoon it's
probably what the weekend did before he
wrote that song I feel my face I'm
pretty sure I'm smelling contact god I
wish and we'll see you when we see you I
don't know and that's not it that's not
it at all like there's more injuries in
a chillin gym than like on the football
field that's a completely different like
competitive it's hard
wow so how long did you do cheerleading
for ever it's at your cheerleading right
now - yeah right now